ON ELECTIONS A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS WILL COME TO ORDER --
BEFORE WE BEGIN LET ME ANNOUNCE
THAT -- SEVERAL BILLS HAVE BEEN
PULLED AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHORS.
AB FIVE OH FOR BERMAN.
A. B. SIX NINE THREE BERMAN AND
A. B. NOT EXCUSE ME A. B. EIGHT
SIX FOUR MULLIN.
INVOLVEMENT PULLED THE REQUEST
THE AUTHOR.
SO -- WILL BEGIN IS A
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE BIRDS ARE
ALL HERE.
WE COULD USE SOME OTHER FOLKS --
IF IF -- LET'S SEE WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN WHO'S HERE --
A WEEK SHE FIRST UP ON OUR LIST.
YES ALL RIGHT.
AB. ONE ZERO FOUR FOUR SO CENTER
NIELSEN ZERO OKAY PERFECT.
BEFORE WE BEGIN LET LET'S -- GO
AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
NUMBER.
NUMBER HERE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HERE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HERE LEYVA
[inaudible]
STERN.
OKAY WE HAVE A CLIP.
WE HAVE A QUORUM ALL RIGHT.
THE LUNAR WOULD GO AHEAD I THANK
YOU CHAIR -- BERG CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT YOUR START TIME
RIGHT ON TIME.
SO AB TEN FORTY FOUR WOULD ALLOW
THE SECRETARY.
BUT A LOT OF THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO REQUIRE APPLICANTS FOR
VOTER REGISTRATION INFORMATION
TO COMPLETE A FREE ONLINE
CYBERSECURITY COURSE OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS TO SEPARATE.
MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS THAT HELD
VOTER REGISTRATION INFORMATION
WERE COMPROMISED BY CYBER
ATTACKS IN ONE CASE DATE WAS
HELD HOSTAGE.
A AS THE ATTACKER HOPE TO
RECEIVE A RANSOM PAID BY BIT
COIN WHILE THE SECRETARY OF
STATE STORES AND RESTRICTS VOTER
REGISTRATION INFORMATION CERTAIN
PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION.
IS MADE AVAILABLE TO APPLICANTS
THAT WILL USE IT FOR POLITICAL
SCHOLARLY JOURNALISTIC OR
GOVERNMENTAL PURPOSES BY
ENSURING THAT THE RECIPIENTS OF
VOTER REGISTRATION.
DATA HAVE COMPLETED BASIC
SECURITY CYBER.
BASICS CYBERSECURITY LESSONS
THIS BILL WILL HELP SAFEGUARD
PERSONAL INFORMATION OF MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS AND WITH ME
TODAY IS A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND CHAIR MY NAME IS
TIFFANY MOCK AND I SERVICE
DEPUTY SECRETARY STATE.
FOR SECRETARY TO DHEA WE ARE
PROUD SPONSOR THIS BILL TODAY TO
HELP ENSURE THE SAFETY OF VOTER
ROLL INFORMATION.
FONG REPORTS OF CYBER SECURITY
THREATS AND ATTACKS DIRECTED AT
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS.
THE SECRETARY ENCOURAGE
CAMPAIGNS AND ELECTED OFFICIALS
TO TAKE PROACTIVE MEASURES TO
INCREASE THEIR DEFENSES AGAINST
CYBER ATTACKS.
MOTOROLA INFORMATION IS
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE TO POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS JOURNALISTS AND
SCHOLARS AND CANNOT BE USED FOR
COMMERCIAL PURPOSES NEVERTHELESS
APPLICANTS MAY LACK KNOWLEDGE.
IN BASIC SECURE DATA STORAGE.
AB TEN FORTY FOUR WOULD ADDRESS
THIS CONCERN AND THE COURSE
WOULD BE FREE TO APPLICANTS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION WE URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS MOCK.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION -- SEEING NONE
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OF BILLS BEEN MOVED -- MADAM
SECRETARY ANY DISCUSSION.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
A JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE THANK YOU -- MAPS ATTRIBUTE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE NUMBER.
NUMBER I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE STERN [inaudible]
OKAY.
I BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN IRWIN AND
PART [inaudible]
THANKS.
ALL RIGHT -- WE HAVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND AND WE'RE LACKING
AUTHORS HERE IN SAN ELECTIONS.
AND THEN LEAVE.
OKAY WELL AS LONG AS YOU LIMITED
BILLS THE ASSEMBLY THAT BE FINE
PROBABLY YEAH -- ALL RIGHT SO IT
IS EMOTIONALLY CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATOR HERTZBERG MOVES ALL
RIGHT -- THEM SECTOR IF YOU CALL
THE ROLL.
NUMBER NUMBER I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE LEYVA LEYVA AYE STERN
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
SO.
THANK YOU I'M INFORMED THAT
AUTHORS ARE ON THEIR WAY
[inaudible]
THE CRAVING
.
GOOD TIMING THANK YOU -- MISS
SURE MEMBERS ARE PRESENT BEFORE
YOU AB SEVENTEEN ALSO KNOWN AS
VOTER PROTECTION ACT.
WOULD ADDRESS VOTER COERCION AND
PROTECT BALLOT INTEGRITY BY
PROHIBITING AN EMPLOYER FROM
REQUIRING A REQUESTING THAT AN
EMPLOYEE.
BRING THE VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT TO
WORK -- WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT -- SUPPORT.
THIS MARKET YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
BY. FIFTY MACH BEHALF OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE WERE
IN SUPPORT OUR OTHER SUPPORT
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
SIGNAL QUESTIONS.
THE LEVEL MOVES A BILL -- WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BY CLASS FOR
NEIGHBORHOOD AND APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT.
EXCELLENT PRESENTATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- MADAM SECRETARY IF
YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL MOTION
IS TO PASS TO SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE NUMBER HI I'M BURKE
AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE LEYVA LEYVA AYE STERN.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT BILLS OUT ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ONE MORE [inaudible]
NO.
ALSO CONSENT SORRY GONE YES
THANK YOU.
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN --
WARD CENTER STERN.
ALL RIGHT AB.
SIX SEVEN NINE THE MOON GONZALEZ
THANK YOU THANK YOU AGAIN.
VERY LITTLE WAITING HERE AND
SEND ELECTIONS WERE TO SERVE.
THE CUSTOMER SEARCHLIGHT.
BUT I LIKE THIS WHAT TO LOOK AT
PAST CHAIRS POINT NOT QUITE AS
EFFECTIVE.
I AM I'M JOKING OWNERS THERE AND
WHERE ARE YOU.
HE IS.
HERE I THINK HE'S UP IN JUDAS
WHERE I WAS -- SO THANK YOU AT
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS
BILL IT IS I'M A VERY I I THINK
SIMPLE BILL IN SOMETHING THAT
BECAME AN ISSUE IN MY DISTRICT
IN MY AREA AND SO ONE THAT WE
THOUGHT WE PURSUE.
BASICALLY THE REALITY IS --
OFTEN BECAUSE THE HOUSING CRISIS
BUT ALSO BECAUSE OF CULTURAL
DIFFERENCES IN IMMIGRANT REFUGEE
POPULATIONS WE HAVE MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE WHO.
MAY HAVE A STOREFRONT BUSINESS --
AND LIVE IN THE BACK OR ABOVE IT
IN AND THAT'S ACTUALLY THE
RESIDENTS IN -- SAN DIEGO AND
I'M SURE IN OTHER PLACES OFTEN
IF YOU HAVE REGISTERED AT EIGHTY
AYE AYE YOUR DOMICILE AT A
BUSINESS ADDRESS I CAN GET
THROWN OUT WE HAD IN FACT.
ELECTION WHERE -- THE DECIDING
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE VOTES WAS
TO VOTE AND WE SAW ABOUT TEN
BALLOTS GET THROWN OUT BECAUSE
THEY WERE BUSINESS ADDRESSES.
THAT WE WANT TO CLARIFY THAT --
A DOMICILE CAN IN FACT BE AT A
BUSINESS ADDRESS OF THE PERSON
ACTUALLY RESIDES THERE THAT'S
ALL THIS BILL DOES RESPECT LAST
FROM ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT -- SUPPORT YOUR ROSE
LEGAL RIVER IS A CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT IS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN WERE CONCERNED OF LOS
AND BIG US ENOUGH. TO LEAVE SOME
CONFUSION RELATED TO
IMPLEMENTATION.
BOTH VOTERS UNDERSTANDING AS TO
WHERE THEY CAN REGISTER AND AND
OFFICIAL BOB PROCESSING AND
ESPECIALLY AS WE RAMP UP.
OF A PROVISIONAL VOTING THROUGH
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
PUT THEIR BUSINESS.
ADDRESS WHERE THEY ARE IN FACT
DOMICILED ON THOSE PROVISIONAL
BALLOT CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION ENVELOPES THAT
THEIR PROCESS CORRECTLY -- AND
AND AS WAS IT IS IT'S CLEAR THAT.
AS WAS INDICATED WE'VE GOT
INCREASINGLY DIFFERENT KINDS OF
HOUSING THAT PEOPLE ARE USING.
AND A STRICT OF DELINEATION
DOESN'T MEET THE REALITY OF
THOSE SORTS OF HOUSING AND JUST
FROM A PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE MY
DAUGHTER JUST GOT MARRIED. TO A
MAN WHOSE PARENTS MANAGE A DRY
CLEANING BUSINESS IN SAN
FRANCISCO THEY LIVE BEHIND IN A
TINY LITTLE ROOM BEHIND THE DRY
CLEANING BUSINESS.
THEY SPEAK CHINESE A SPEAK
CANTONESE THEY'RE ALREADY
CONFUSED ENOUGH ABOUT THE
REGULATIONS THE LAWS THEY'RE A
LITTLE BIT AFRAID.
OF SUCH THINGS LIKE FOOD
REGISTRATION BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO MAKE A MISTAKE IN THOSE
ARE THE SORTS OF FOLKS UNDER
REPRESENTED VOTERS -- IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE ARE ABLE TO REGISTER
WITHOUT.
CONCERNS LIKE THAT IS WHEN THEY
LIVE -- AT THE PLACE THAT THEY
DO BUSINESS [inaudible]
THANK YOU. TO ME OTHERS IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
MR.
GO AHEAD ASK YOUR QUESTION SEVEN
HERTZBERG AND WILL TAKE IT OFF
THERE'S JUST A MOST OF OUR
HISTORY PEOPLE DID LIVE WITH
THEIR WORK YOU KNOW THE WALK UPS
AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS THAT.
HE WAS DESTINY IS BORN INTO
PLACES EMPHASIS GOERS PARENTS
LIVED IN THE ON THE SAME SIDE
THAT HAS BEEN THE HISTORY -- I'M
JUST WONDER WHAT THE REASON FOR
THE RULE WAS TO SEPARATE AS LONG
AS YOU LIVE IN THE SAME
JURISDICTION I EAT ARE QUITE
FRANKLY USED TO REGISTER MY LAW
OFFICE.
BUT MY LAW OFFICES TWO BLOCKS
AWAY FROM WHERE BY APARTMENT WAS
AND IT WAS THE SAME JURISDICTION
SO I JUST MAYES SAMPRAS LIKE
GETTING ALL MY MAIL IN ONE PLACE.
WHAT DIFFERENCE DOES IT MAKE AS
LONG AS YOU'RE NOT?
MR DISTINCTION -- DIFFERENCES
SEEMS TO ME AND AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOING BACK TO THE FUTURE
IN A SENSE OF THESE THINGS WE
MAKE THESE EXAMPLES I MEAN THIS
IS BEEN SO MUCH OF HOW WE'VE
LIVED OUR LIVES AS ONE WHEN THE
LAW WAS CHANGED IS KIND OF
INTERESTING TO ME.
WE ARE TRYING TO PHONY ANYBODY
UP YOU JUST WANNA MAKE
CONVENIENCE.
SO WHILE I DON'T WANNA --
SUGGEST TO YOU THAT YOU MIGHT A
BROKEN THE LAW WHEN YOU REGISTER
TO YOUR LOT ACTUALLY.
HOWEVER I I'M SURE STATURE
LIMITATIONS IS RUN -- BUT BUT I
THINK THAT IT'S YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY WE WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE GAMING THE SYSTEM YOU
KNOW WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE
REGISTERING AND TO A DIFFERENT --
DISTRICT.
ESPECIALLY TO RUN FOR OFFICE
BECAUSE OUR BUSINESSES THERE BUT
THE REALITIES OF TODAY'S WORLD
IS THAT WE DO ONCE AGAIN -- AT
RETURN I GUESS TO HOUSING CRISIS
A LARGE IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS
REFUGEE POPULATIONS AROUND SMALL
BUSINESSES OFTEN -- HELP THE
SITUATION COME UP [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
I YES MY NAME IS COLIN BRITAIN
I'M WITH THE ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
AND ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSES AB.
SIX NINETY SIX SEVENTY NINE WE
BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD FACILITATE
UNLIMITED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
REGISTRATION FRAUD AND REMOVE
THE ABILITY TO MAINTAIN ACCURATE
VOTER ROLLS OF FAT EFFICIENTLY.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A VOTERS
REGISTER IN A RED AT A
RESIDENTIAL STREET ADDRESS NOT A
POST OFFICE BOX OR BUSINESS
ADDRESS AB.
SIX SEVENTY NINE WOULD ALLOW IN
INDIVIDUALS TO BE LEGALLY
REGISTERED AT A BUSINESS ADDRESS
UNDER CERTAIN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THAT ARE IMPOSSIBLE TO RESEARCH
OR VERIFY.
THOSE CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
WHEN A PERSON SEPARATES FROM THE
FAMILY AND TAKES UP RESIDENCE IN
A LOCATION OF THEIR BUSINESS.
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
SEPARATE FROM FAMILY AND ALSO
OWN A BUSINESS ESTABLISHMENT
THAT LENDS ITSELF TO BEING
INCLUDED.
AS A RESIDENTIAL SITUATION MUST
BE FAIRLY RARE BUT IF A THE SIX
SIX SEVENTY NINE IS AN ACTIVE
VOTER ROLLS CAN NO LONGER BE
RESEARCH TO FOR ILLEGAL ADDRESS.
REGISTRATIONS BECAUSE OF
THIRTIES WOULD HAVE TO ASSUME.
THAT EVERYONE REGISTERED AT A
BUSINESS ADDRESS IS LIVING THERE
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES ALLOWED
BY THE LAW.
THIS FACILITATES A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY FOR REGISTRATION
FRAUD.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA
DATA TEAM.
FOUND THAT NO SMALL NUMBER OF
BUSINESSES BUSINESS
ESTABLISHMENTS FROM FAST FOOD
RESTAURANTS TO PSYCHIATRISTS
OFFICE.
I HAD A HIGH NUMBERS OF
REGISTRATIONS OFTEN ISN'T AS AT
AND ABOVE.
ALTHOUGH A SMALL NUMBER OF THESE
PEOPLE MAY BE REGISTERED LEGALLY
BECAUSE OF THE HOMELESS
CONDITION.
THE MAJORITY ARE NOT AND MUST BE
REMOVED FROM THE ROLLS.
AB SIX SEVENTY NINE WOULD
COMPLICATE SUCH VOTER ROLL MAIN
MAINTENANCE TO THE POINT OF
IMPOSSIBILITY.
THE SITUATION PRESENTS A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY FOR REGISTRATION
FRAUD AND SHOULD NOT BE ENACTED.
THE ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSES THIS
BILL AB SIX SEVENTY NINE THANK
YOU.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM -- OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE --
QUESTIONS ALRIGHT HELLO MOVES --
THE BILL.
WOULD LIKE CLOSE THE MOON
THEMSELVES DISRESPECT LAST WHEN
I VOTED IN FRANCHISE AS MANY
PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU.
BUT SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THERE'S A TO PASS NUMBER HI
AMBER GUY NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE STERN.
STERN I OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT WE HAVE A OBERNOLTE THAT THE
BILLS OUT -- WE HAVE ONE MORE
BILL -- ASSEMBLY.
I'M SORRY THE OBERNOLTE.
WHAT IS?
THE THE A YEAH -- WELL MADAM
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
OPEN THE ROLE -- ON THE MATTER
AS WE WILL REFUND TODAY.
SB SEVENTEEN SALAS MOTIONS IT IS
DUE PASSED THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOR EYES AND
NO KNOWS WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
STERN.
DURING THE TIME.
AB SIX SEVENTY NINE GONZALEZ
MOTION IS TO PASS CURRENT VOTE
IS -- YOU ALREADY DID THAT --
ONE AB -- TEN FORTY FOUR WHEN
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOR EYES NO NOSE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I STERN.
STERN HI THEN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
STERN [inaudible]
STERN I OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS TODAY IF
WE CAN GET ALL THE MEMBERS
SUPPOSE UNDER THE CLOCK I'D LIKE
TO RECORD THIS FOR POSTERITY
THAT WE'RE FINISHED IN TWENTY
MINUTES ACTUALLY NINETEEN
MINUTES OR SO.
SO -- REV EFFICIENT RIGHT ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE'RE GERM